no one would have believed in the last
years of the 19th century that this
world was being watched keenly and
closely by intelligences greater than
men you may know HG Wells for his iconic
science fiction stories War of the
Worlds the Invisible Man The Time
Machine but here are five things you
might not have known although he never
became an academic as a young man Welles
won a scholarship to Imperial College
London where he studied under the
eminent biologist T H Huxley a
contemporary of Charles Darwin's wells
was friends with astronomer Richard
Gregory who was also the editor of
nature over the years Wells wrote essays
correspondences and commentaries for
nature's pages in fact Wells didn't
describe himself as a scientist or an
artist but as a journalist the first two
books that Wells published were
textbooks this biology reference book
was so popular that it ran into many
editions unlike most prominent figures
of his day Welles was from a poor family
his parents were born as servants and
later became shopkeepers Welles himself
escaped apprenticeships and Draper's
shops to follow the path of an
intellectual inspiring his lifelong
reverence for education okay that is a
bit of a stretch but he did propose
something eerily similar in a lecture in
1936 Welles presented what he called the
world brain he described an encyclopedia
which should be alive and growing and
changing continually under revision
extension and replacement from the
original thinkers in the world
everywhere he added that its contents
would be the standard source of material
for the instructional side of school and
college work for the verification of
facts and the testing of statements
sound familiar so to recap Herbert
George Wells was a scientifically
trained textbook writing son of
shopkeepers who published not only some
of the world's most influential science
fiction but also political social and
scientific commentary in journals like
Nature oh and he proposed a version of
Wikipedia almost half a century before
anyone
even heard of the web well-done wells